we were exclusively on the set with the
cast and Istanbul to bring you this
first look but I have so many talents a
money outstanding a Jewish Kristen
Stewart Aladdin's Naomi Scott and
newcomer Ella by lenska make up the new
trio of angels we're on a ferry and
Istanbul filming Charlie's Angels who
likes doing the crazy fight sequences
the most you think are you all just
something happens they call action and
like all the rehearsal just flies out
the window and you're like I'm gonna
kill her yeah Elena wouldn't you - no no
I'm Jane oh but don't call this a reboot
or a remake this is a new generation of
an entirely new Charlie's Angels story
written directed and produced by
Elizabeth Banks oh and she also co-stars
who are you embossing
I've always feel safe in the scene where
an actor is like a dream are you
developing a sisterhood off screen -
when you're in the trenches together
happens oh I love that so much the full
trailer launches tomorrow morning and
get this you're gonna get to hear a new
song - it features no big deal
ariana grande Miley Cyrus and Lana Del
Rey whoo all right
[Music]